okay I do want to just very quickly talk
about a situation that caused a
significant amount of panic when I
talked about it on the Wednesday show I
gave the backstory about the YouTube ad
pocalypse and how the YouTube channel
for the David Pakman show seems to have
settled at only 15 percent of the
revenue that we previously were
experiencing on the YouTube channel and
I started getting panicked emails Pat
reminiscent of my panicked face here
which we call panicked David which
people who are watching the show on
YouTube or on TV may be seeing right now
thinking that I'm basically saying the
show is about to end like today or
tomorrow that's not the case
okay so again to to present a non
hyperbolic explanation of what is and
isn't going on YouTube ad pocalypse
started it affected our channel
significantly the New York Times wrote
an article about what was going on great
article by Amanda Hess about our YouTube
channel wired wrote an article by Davey
Alba about what is going on with the
David Pakman show YouTube channel and it
represented what is shown by this
revenue curve that I'm putting up on the
screen for you as you can see we started
the year very very strongly near the
number one at the left of your screen
when the YouTube advertiser boycott
started we got down to point two on the
revenue curve and as you can see that
was a roughly 99 percent decrease in
revenue at point three in the curve that
I'm showing you we recovered about a
third of the revenue but sadly over the
last 10 or 12 days we are down 2.4 on
this graphic that our TV audience is
seeing and that is a loss of about 85
percent of our revenue so the point I
made yesterday two days ago that I want
to make again is to continue the
trajectory of expansion and to avoid
having to contract our offerings this is
revenue that we have to make up and this
can be done a few different ways I've
talked about this before and I'll
mention it again number one through
membership you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership membership
comes with some great member benefits
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 to get a 40% discount
you can become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is great
for quick small donations if you don't
want to create an account on our website
and just want to throw a dollar or two a
month our way and number three if you
ever shop on amazon.com you can go to
david pakman.com slash amazon membership
has been a really really great thing
many people signing up for membership in
response to what has been going on and
membership gets you the commercial-free
all-access pass as well as instant
access to the bonus show also patreon
very very simple and we have crested the
1600 patron mark as of yesterday and
that has been a big big help so I want
to be super clear the shows not ending
tomorrow but if we want to continue
doing everything we've been doing and
everything we want to continue doing and
I think that there's no more important
time to be doing that we do need to make
up the lost revenue and I think that
that we've presented a variety of
options for people to support us if they
can and you know what if you genuinely
can't afford $1 a month I don't want you
to contribute because I still want to be
doing the show for you and it should be
accessible for free but if you can
contribute as little as a dollar a month
this is the time to do it so the
situation seems less like the panic
David that we would see if there was a
tornado coming but with the raindrops
drip drip dripping maybe there's a flood
ensuing and you're concerned David I'm
liking this water analogy I'm liking the
water analogy to the extent that I
understand it and that is a you know
roughly a 20 30 % understanding right
now but we'll talk about that later in
any case people I want to tell you Pat
and I want to tell everybody else who's
watching the show is not ending tomorrow
but this is something that we are
working on fixing and I appreciate
everyone's help in fixing it I'm on
Twitter at Dee Pakman if you have
anything else to tell me about this
issue we're also on twitter at david
pakman show